[Music]
all right let's get a fire started
[Music]
there's some bar hey tell me you're
gonna join us yeah great
mama are you doing oh I'm so glad to see
you and Jacob you guys having fun eating
dinner by the campfire yeah and do you
know what's happening in a couple days
Halloween right you guys want to tell
some scary stories tonight yeah all
right
let's tell some scary campfire stories
let me tell you a true story a scary
story about an Alaskan killer grizzly
bear or we start I need to tell you guys
a little bit about Kodiak Island now
Kodiak Island is a little bit south of
Anchorage it's a big island full of deer
and salmon and killer grizzly bears
these bears get over 11 feet tall you
know Kodiak grizzly bears are so fast
they can outrun deer and they like to
attack hunters when they hear a gun go
off they know that someone shot a deer
so they run over and attack the hunter
and take his deer many hunters have been
killed by grizzly bears and when they
shot him their bullets did nothing but I
know somebody tougher than a Kodiak
grizzly bear his name was Jean Moe and
one day Jean with deer hunting on Kodiak
Island Jean took a boat from Kodiak city
to a remote part of the island landed
his boat and then
hiked many miles looking for deer he
found a deer shot it and he was cutting
it well gene took his gun and leaned it
against a tree while he was gutting the
deer with his hunting knife and little
did he know a Kodiak grizzly bear had
heard his gunshot and had come to attack
him and take his deer the bear snuck up
quiet stealthy behind gene and then it
jumped on him and all he had to defend
himself was his knife the bear
immediately started clawing his face and
his head and his back and gene started
stabbing the bear as hard as he could
with his hunting knife Kodiak grizzly
bear grabbed gene in his mouth
and started shaking him back and forth
like a dog would shake a toy and gene
stabbed the bear as it was trying to
kill him the bear toot up his arms and
it chewed up his legs and the whole time
as it was eating his arms and legs
Dean kept stabbing the bear with his
knife he fought the bear and fought the
bear and wouldn't die no matter how many
times did their bid him know how many
pieces the bear tore off him he wouldn't
die the bear bit off his bicep on his
right arm bit off chunk of his thigh on
his right leg and turned his back into
applesauce he was a bloody horrible mess
but you know what gene did he stabbed a
Kodiak grizzly bear to death and after
the bear collapsed from blood loss gene
took up all of his pieces walked over
got his gun and shot that bear now
anybody can stab a bear to death law is
eating your arms and legs that's just
standard operating procedure in Alaska
but what made gene the toughest guy ever
is it after he killed the bear skinned
it he took that hide put it on his
bloody back and then he hiked the miles
back to the shore to get on the boat and
then go back to Kodiak City then go and
fly to Anchorage and then go to the
hospital now gene was not a man who
brags a lot and you know how I found out
about him stabbing the bear to death
well gene sent the bear hide to his
taxidermist to get it turned into a rug
and when the taxidermist saw the bear
hide it had 40 stab holes all in the
hide so the taxidermist got on the phone
and called gene and said what did you do
to this hide it's torn to pieces and you
know what gene said it's hard to skin
him when they're moving
well Gene's taxidermist told the local
newspapers so next time I saw gene at
the construction site I said gene I
heard you stabbed a bear to death while
I was eaten yeah and then he dropped his
pants and showed me all of his bite mark
and he showed me where the doctors had
sewn the meat back onto his arm and sewn
the meat back onto his leg and that was
gene moe the man so tough he stabbed a
bear to death while I was eating it and
do you know what right now I hear that
there's a bear in our neighborhood and
at any moment it could come and grab one
of you and start eating you too well
guys we hope you enjoyed this scary
little campfire story with the outdoor
boy's youtube channel we hope you have a
great Halloween and don't forget to we
put out new videos every Saturday
morning thanks for watching if you like
this video don't forget to check out the
outdoor boys even Channel
we have hundreds of videos just like
this and don't forget to click subscribe
so you can see other great videos every
Saturday morning hit that belt like
you'll get notifications thanks for
watching